bien avant l'histoire d'amour avec le
prince harry il y a eu celle avec la
ville reine
megan marcory a vécu pendant six heures
lorsqu'elle tournait la télésérie
américaine soute
c'est d'ailleurs à toronto que le couple
princier a fait sa première sortie
publique l'an passé lors des jeux
invictus parrainé par harry lorsqu'elle
habitait à toronto c'est ici que mes
guides marco avait élu domicile dans le
quartier branché dits annexes
la future princesse a bien documenté sur
instagram ces années passées dans cette
maison louée la demeure subit en ce
moment une transformation majeure la
maison achetée pour la somme de 500
mille dollars en 2007 par les anciens
propriétaires ont récemment été revendu
plus deux millions et demi de dollars
elle se décrit comme une amatrice de
bons repas meghan markle venait au moins
une fois par mois ici à la tisch
boutique elle aime bien manger dit le
propriétaire de l'endroit et les
cultiver et elle a beaucoup voyagé et là
un ballet très fins utiles parmi ces
produits fétiches du pain et son beurre
de normandie l'expression minutes marc
collat toujours été amicale selon
affrime christine elle ne jouait pas à
la vedette chinoise tang est l'autre
quartier fréquenté par megamark au queen
ouest petit bijou de toronto ou bars et
restaurants de toutes sortes côtoient et
où l'on retrouve un des plus beaux parcs
de la ville
le réputé magazine vogue d'ailleurs
nommé queen ouest dans ces quartiers les
plus branchés de la planète il ya quatre
ans évidemment qu'il venait dans ce parc
s'exclame cette résidente mégane
marcoule est à la mode faire un
reportage sur toronto et mégane marco
sans mentionner les waters et ses blue
jays serait un sacrilège
elle a assisté à quelques parties avec
sa meilleure amie jessica moroni les
push de belles moroni dont les enfants
seront en vedette au mariage samedi ici
philippe leblanc radio canada toronto